monsieur jean pierre door merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé les droits des femmes
j'y associe mon collègue arnaud robinet
et mes collègues du groupe l'est
républicain
madame la ministre le tiers payant
généralisé votre dispositif symbolique
contesté avec force par l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
combattue par votre opposition durant
les longs débats parlementaires vient
d'être censuré censurée en partie par le
conseil constitutionnel au motif que le
dispositif est mal encadré et que le
législateur a méconnu l'étendue de ses
compétences c'est un revers politique
c'est un véritable camouflet humiliant
pour toute votre administration
cela prouve que le groupe des
républicains avaient raison de déposer
ce recours est aujourd'hui cela nous
renforce dans l'engagement d'abroger
votre loi des l'alternance de 2017 ne
nous dit pas ne le dites pas madame la
ministre comme d'habitude que cela est
insignifiant et que vous restez
convaincu d'avoir raison réseau contre
les conséquences pratiques pour les
médecins libéraux que vous jugez
finalement comme des adversaires
vous avez surtout méconnu l'organisation
et le fonctionnement de notre système de
financement celui des régimes
obligatoires et le financement des
complémentaires qui transforme le tiers
payant généralisé en une mission
impossible
madame la ministre dispositif devait
devenir obligatoire dans les médecins
généralistes
il a sérieusement du plomb dans les
ailes le tiers payant généralisé doit
être facultatif
alors laisserez-vous le libre choix aux
professionnels de santé
il ne vous demande pas l'aumône mais il
se demande simplement d'être reconnu
merci la parole est à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé des droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean-pierre door
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que
le conseil constitutionnel a validé la
totalité des mesures et notamment des
mesures phares qui lie à dans la loi de
modernisation de notre système de santé
puisque le conseil constitutionnel a
validé par exemple le rétablissement du
service hospitalier contre ce que vous
souhaitiez la mise en place du paquet de
cigarettes neutre l'expérimentation des
salles de consommation à moindre risque
la création de l'action de groupe en
matière de santé la suppression du délai
de réflexion pour l'interruption
volontaire d'une vous plains me coûte du
droit à l'oubli
autant de mesures qui figurent dans
cette loi et le conseil constitutionnel
monsieur le député a validé le principe
du tiers payant
le tiers payant se mettra en place cette
année comme prévu à partir du 1er
juillet prochain
ce sont 15 millions de français qui
progressivement pourront bénéficier du
tiers payant ce sont ceux qui sont pris
en charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie
notamment les femmes enceintes et les
malades graves à partir de 2017 pour les
autres patients qu est ce qu a dit le
conseil constitutionnel
il a dit que le tiers payant pouvait se
mettre en place de façon obligatoire
pour l'ensemble des médecins
en ce qui concerne la partie remboursée
par l'assurance maladie obligatoire et
que pour ce qui est remboursé par les
complémentaires
il appartiendrait aux médecins de voir
s'il le faisait ou pas c'est pour cela
que nous allons proposer et mettre en
place un système très simple parce que
je veux dire ma confiance
à partir du moment où les médecins
devront pratiquer le tiers payant pour
la partie remboursée par l'assurance
maladie
ils souhaiteront évidemment avoir un
système le plus simple possible pour
pouvoir pratiquer le tiers payant sur
l'intégralité des honoraires de leurs
consultations
et c'est cela l'objectif à terme la
ministre la parole est à monsieur
ibrahim aboubacar